so my mother's a pediatrician and when I
was young she tell the craziest stories
that combined science with her
overactive imagination one of the
stories she told was that if you eat a
lot of salt all the blood rushes up your
legs through your body
and she's at the top of your head
killing you instantly she called it high
blood pressure this was my first
experience of science fiction and I
loved it so when I started to write my
own science fiction and fantasy
I was surprised that it was considered
an African so naturally i asked what is
african and this is what I know so far
Africa is important Africa is the future
it is though and Africa is a serious
place where only serious things happen
so when I present my work somewhere
someway we'll always ask what's so
important about it how does it deal with
real African issues like war poverty
devastation or AIDS and it doesn't my
work is about Nairobi pop bands that
want to go to space or about 7 foot tall
robots that fall in love it's nothing
incredibly important it's just fun
fierce and frivolous as frivolous as
bubblegum afro bubblegum so I'm not
saying that agenda art isn't important
I'm the chairperson of a charity the
deals with films and theaters that write
about HIV and radicalization and female
genital mutilation it's vital and
important art but it cannot be the only
art that comes out of the continent we
have to tell more stories that are
vibrant this danger of the single story
is still being realized and maybe it's
because of the funding a lot of
is still dependent on developmental aid
so art becomes a two-for agenda or maybe
it's because we've only seen one image
of ourselves for so long that that's all
we know how to create whatever the
reason we need a new way and afro
bubblegum is one approach
it's the advocacy of art for art's sake
it's the advocacy of art that is not
policy driven or agenda driven or based
on education just for the sake of
imagination afro bubblegum aren't and we
can't all be often Bob chemists we have
to judge our work for its potential
poverty porn pitfalls we have to have
tests that are similar to the Bechdel
test and ask questions like are two or
more Africans in this piece of fiction
healthy are those same Africans
financially stable and not in need of
saving
are they having fun and enjoying life
and if we can answer yes to two or more
of these questions and surely we offer
bubblegum mists
and fun is political because imagine if
we have images of Africans who were
vibrant and loving and thriving and
living a beautiful vibrant life what
would we think of ourselves then would
we think that maybe were worthy of more
happiness would we think of our shared
humanity through our shared joy I think
of these things when I create I think of
the people and the places that give me
immeasurable joy and I work to represent
them and that's why I write stories
about futuristic girls that risk
everything to save plants or to race
camels or even just to dance to honor
fun because my world is mostly happy and
I know happiness is a privilege in this
current splintered world where remaining
hopeful requires diligence but maybe if
you join me in creating curating and
commissioning more Afra bubblegum art
there might be hope for a different view
of the world a happy Africa view where
children are strangely traumatized by
their mother's drug sense of humor but
also their claiming fun fierce and
frivolous art in the name of all things
unserious Lee African because we're afro
bubble comest and there's so many more
of us than you can imagine
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]